Avengers in-game is back in theaters
worldwide with six minutes of additional
footage how's it going everyone it's
worn and the re-release of Avengers in
game is officially out this weekend
there had been a lot of rumors about
what we could expect to see with the
re-release but now we officially know
there is a new tribute to Stan Lee there
is a new Hulk deleted scene that didn't
make it in Avengers in game and there is
a clip from spider-man far from home so
I'll break down what happens in each of
these scenes in this video but first if
you would like a chance to win a Captain
America shield an Iron Man helmet and
Infinity Gauntlet or another Marvel
Legends item feature subscribe to my
channel so you can enter my giveaway at
four hundred and fifty thousand
subscribers I'll be picking three new
winners so this comes from my buddy who
lives in the UK who caught an early
screening of The Avengers in game
re-released this morning and saw all of
the new footage so to start off there is
a new tribute to Stan Lee and it is
definitely a tearjerker and very
heartfelt the new tribute is a set up
and a dedication to Stan Lee as one of
the greatest comic book creators of all
time the tribute was also a recap of
Stan Lee's time in the MCU and about how
his characters went on to be icons and
make millions of dollars it was a great
tribute to Stan Lee as he is definitely
missed at the very end of the movie
there is a new spider-man far from home
clip it's very short probably about 30
seconds long and then it cuts to a
trailer that we've seen before and then
of course we have the New Avengers
in-game post-credit scene which is just
a deleted scene that was unfinished and
was not included in the original version
of Avengers end game sadly this scene is
something that we already knew as it was
leaked earlier on this week the scene is
of the Hulk running into a burning
building saving some children now there
are some people out there right now that
says this has something to do with phase
4 and even though I would really love to
tell you that unfortunately that is not
the case Kevin Feige the president of
Marvel Studios has already come out and
said that this was a deleted scene from
Avengers in game that did not make it
into the movie therefore this would have
happened during Avengers in game before
the time-travel and before the final
battle this scene is actually probably
why we see the Hulk is pretty popular
with the children and they want to take
pictures with him the Hulk is a hero for
saving lives and
you watched the scene the CGI isn't even
completely done Kevin Feige mentioned
this as well he said that it was a
deleted unfinished scene from Avengers
endgame
there were some other deleted scenes
that we were hoping to get with this
re-release of Avengers in game the scene
with Tony Stark and his adult daughter
Morgan Stark in Soul world was one of
them there is also a deleted scene with
the Hulk which is what everybody
actually thought we were going to see
where he is in the gambit chamber and he
turns into professor Hulk these are
scenes that people really want to see
and hope that we would see with the
re-release of Avengers in game but
hopefully we get these with the release
of the blu-ray for Avengers in game so
sadly there is no relation to phase 4
with this new post-credit scene that we
have for Avengers endgame so sadly
there's not really much here with this
new release of Avengers in game the new
tribute to Stan Lee is definitely
awesome and a tearjerker and even though
the Hulk scene is unfinished it's kind
of cool to see as well and there is a
new clip for spider-man far from home at
the end but sadly nothing pointing to
the future of the MCU Kevin Feige did
say that they will not announce anything
until after the release of spider-man
far from home and it seems like they are
sticking to it but fortunately for us
San Diego comic-con is right around the
corner so we'll learn more about phase 4
then be sure to comment and let me know
how you feel about the new material and
the Avengers in-game re-release the Stan
Lee tribute the spider-man fire from
home clip and the new deleted scene with
the Hulk and of course be sure to like
the video and subscribe to my channel if
you would like to enter my giveaway and
stay up to date on everything relating
to Marvel and the MCU
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof